yeah welcome to all the new people sorry
if i'm not
seeing your comments saying that you're
watching for the first time but i do
appreciate the new viewers
um usually when i'm playing live
and in the midst of a game i won't look
so much a chat
but other people in chat can say hi to
the new people
let's play e4 oh maybe i'll have another
ponziani
also thank you b strike and squid ball
face
two new subs with prime really
appreciate that
okay so ponziani queen a4
there should be no dirty flagging
because we're playing three plus two
oh thank you decude
i'll try and rely on skill rather than
luck but
extra luck is never a bad thing
hmm yeah this is maybe one of the most
natural moves but you just got to send
it
send it oh thanks for sending it yeah
this move was actually a mistake
now black's in a little bit of trouble
queen takes side bishop e5
now bishop c4 queen's tied down to this
pawn
i'm very very quick quick to castle
and black really hasn't developed the
king side at all
i remember studying this actually i
really remember some idea in d3 and
bishop f4
might do it
yeah because i'm also trying to open the
the file
[Music]
and if takes bishop f4 the queen's tied
down again to the pawn
[Music]
so why not
if takes i win the the rook
yeah this ponziani line it usually works
against like
much lower rated players but i guess it
can also work against uh
higher rated players
wow oh there's knight g4 in the end
wait what's the point king d8
oh black wants to sack and attack
i mean i kind of committed myself to win
material
am i getting mated though
g3
g3 h4 okay let's take and
hopefully survive okay so there's made
in one threat
um i mean i have queen queen d5 queen h5
is also interesting
oh thanks for all the hype i appreciate
the the train
of hype
how do you say that's in spanish
el train de hipe
wait what to do here
in queen h i guess queen h5 the queen's
awkward and there's g6
if this move
there's queen h6
and then i kind of have to play h4
ah there's a cool line uh here here here
regardless of whether black takes or
plays g5 i do have bishop a6 going for
my own attack let's do this
it's gonna get confusing
i also have queen d5 here but let's
start with this
that's actually very confusing here
oh even better if g5
i'm assuming g5 if bishop
how dangerous is this bishop takes i
could take on e4 probably
so i'm thinking g5 i oh never mind so
bishop takes wow
i mean my thought was queen d5 bishop d7
and then this move
one's knight f6 oh but now they move
back
king e7 i win the rook but it's scary
okay let's start with this
if king moves i take the pawn with check
i don't think i can get away with taking
the bishop
and then maybe i'd have to bail out with
a draw there's some weird perpetual
how do i do this
really am i meeting now
i mean now i i can just take the pawn i
can also take on f7
so why not do this first
not sure if that helped i'm taking all
the pawns with check
and now i can take the bishop
no now i can check again and then get my
rook involved
it's nice having increment
it's very very nice
the thing is box not even threatening to
check me
so i can keep attacking
i just gotta move quickly
probably take the rook next
wait a minute let's
okay i'll take the rook
it's still weird no this is winning now
right
king of five now i take here with chuck
in kudos my opponent for surviving for
so long
both trying to attack on the same side
check where's my mate
check okay i just want to trade
queens now probably king h4 is funny
if anything blocks on e5 i take it if
king here i move here
now this game got really weird
wow opposition coming check
i'm still not quite meeting but it's
winning
here's mate okay
what a game man
i'm sure i'm sure the engine will say i
was just winning the whole time but i
mean from a practical standpoint given
the time situation
uh
oh queen d5 is the only way to win which
i played
bishop d7
[Music]
i have to go oh i have to go for this
idea quinn 8 would just repeat
yeah i wasn't sure about this actually
because knight of six
oh then i go back king seven
and this is this is terrifying like i
win both rooks but
oh blocks winning what
ramone i thought queen takes h8 the
computer still said white's winning
so this would be losing because takes
and takes knight g4
i was scared of like the prospect of
black
getting an attack and i don't have any
checks
um so queen a7
oh to check on c5 yeah very messy
position
but yeah if we go back to kind of the
opening
the basics of the ponziani if you play
the ponziani or if you want to learn the
ponziani
this is one line to to know
it's actually one of the very few lines
in ponziani where you don't play d4
on mu4 like after d5 best move is queen
a4
and it puts black in a situation you're
threatening to take the pawn
and like moves like this or this they
defend e5 but they lose d5
because they would block the queen um
so we look on leeches most played move
is d takes e4 which is a mistake
because now the knight's attacked and
the pawns attacked
i had a student once this was many many
years ago
[Music]
uh who's playing white i think she was
like 1200 at the time
cool you dad oh because you're a baby
well thanks son for
[Music]
[Music]
yeah my um a student who was 1200 at the
time
was playing a 1600 and
my student was white took on c6
her opponent took with the queen this is
like a
an over the board game and she played
this move and won the
one the queen and the great thing was i
showed her like exactly this position
in like a a prior lesson so
yeah black has to take with a pawn here
and then
[Music]
yeah it's nice having preparation even
beyond this point
like knowing this idea d3 bishop f4 just
very rapid development
so um yeah maybe that's youtube really
i need more ponziani content on youtube
to balance out the stafford gambit
content
so this goes on youtube thanks youtube
people for watching
uh be sure to like and subscribe if you
have not already
it helps algorithm and say hi to gavilan
who just subbed with prime oh if you're
if you're watching on youtube and you
have amazon prime
you can subscribe for free
and it supports the channel so i do get
money from
from prime subs so i do appreciate those
who sub with prime
and yeah stay tuned for more content